[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es eine grundrezept ich
werde euch zeigen wie man quark öl teig
zubereitet ich bin ja ein fan von
hefeteig süß oder herzhaft in allen
variationen und ich liebe es hefeteig
lange zu kneten und auch aufgehen zu
lassen und dann was tolles daraus zu
kreieren
wenn du aber mal schnell gehen muss ist
hefeteig vielleicht nicht ganz die beste
wahl
dann ist der quark öl teig ein idealer
ersatz und quark öl teig es auch im
super leckerer teig erinnert mich auch
geschmacklich ein bisschen und hefeteig
und da ist einfach super fluffig locker
leicht und man kann wirklich alles damit
machen obstkuchen sind schnecken kleine
teilchen des super vielseitig ihr
braucht nur wenige zutaten und die habe
ich auch immer zu hause für den süßen
quark öl teig verwende ich 150 gramm
magerquark 1 1 300 gramm mehl ein
päckchen backpulver 75 g zucker 40 gramm
sonnenblumenöl etwas vanille extrakt und
eine prise salz
die zubereitung ist ganz einfach und ist
nur beachten dass der teig nicht lange
geknetet wird also wirklich alles nur
ganz ganz kurz verbinden weil ich ja
auch gut weil dann hat man eben zeit
gespart
dafür gebe ich jetzt einfach alle
zutaten in der küchenmaschine falls er
denn wieder hand zubereitet dann führe
jetzt erstmal die flüssigen zutaten also
quasi vanille extrakt und öl und dann
können da die trockenen zutaten ganz
kurz ein kneten
so verbindet sich nämlich alles ein
bisserl besser eintreiben vanille
extrakt nämlich sowieso immer ganz gerne
für den geschmack und den teig könnt ihr
auch wirklich ideal aufpimpen mit zum
beispiel zitronenschalen abrieb oder mit
zimt ihr könnt auch ein paar nüsse noch
mit rein geben oder andere aromen
wirklich das was ihr wollt so kam ich
rein und salz und ich gebe jetzt bei
dieser variante noch ein bisschen
zitrone mit rein und dann müsst ihr nur
darauf achten dass sie eine unbehandelte
zitrone verwendet und dann nur den
gelben teil von der schale ab red und
jetzt können die zutaten kurz verbunden
werden
der teig ist es schön weich und klebt
nicht und wenn er mal zu fest ist weil
es zum beispiel zu klein war können die
auch ein schluck milch dazugeben und das
mache ich zum beispiel auch gerne um den
teig etwas flüssiger zu machen um
beispielsweise einen obstkuchen boden zu
machen jetzt bereitet daraus aber erst
einmal keine teil hinzu jetzt bereite
ich leckere teilchen so mit zimt zucker
und dafür will ich jetzt den teig
einfach mal kurz gleichmäßig auf etwas
mehl aus
[Musik]
dann könnte einfach formen eurer wahl
aus schlecht
[Musik]
und den restlichen teig greulich jetzt
noch dünner aus und kann ihn dann
ausstechen und dann sogar füllen
[Musik]
und hier gebe ich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen nougat rein
[Musik]
wenn ihr möchtet können sie die teilchen
jetzt mit etwas eiweiß bestreichen so
bekommen sie einen schönen glanz und
nach dem backen werden sie damit zum
zucker bestreut
[Musik]
wer den oft kuchen mache ich jetzt einen
quark öl teig der ein bisschen flüssiger
ist also gebe ich jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen milch dazu
[Musik]
so habe ich jetzt nämlich den vorteil
und muss das ganze nicht ausrollen
sondern kann den teig mit meiner teig
karte oder meinem körper einfach in die
form streichen
[Musik]
und hier läge jetzt gleich obst drauf da
können wir wirklich kirschen zwetschgen
äpfel rubber erdbeeren egal was da drauf
legen klein geschnitten und dann zum
beispiel noch streusel zu bereiten und
das mache ich jetzt auch und zwar
verwende ich dafür einfach 150 gramm
mehl eine prise salz etwas zimt vanille
extrakt 100 gramm zucker und 100 gramm
butter und für die streusel werden die
zutaten jetzt kurz vermengt
[Musik]
so sehen jetzt die kleinen quack
teilchen aus die gefüllten sind
natürlich extrem lecker und mir
schmecken die warme um alle allerbesten
denn dann ist der nur gerade noch
richtig schön warm und weich legal
videos schon drei gegessen jetzt sogar
mein herzchen austritt
und hier habe ich denn obstkuchen den
habe ich nach dem abkühlen einfach mit
süßem schnee bestreut und wenn du willst
kannst ja einfach mal probieren aus
diesem teil könnt ihr zum beispiel auch
richtig kohle zentrum machen oder auch
anderes gebäck also wirklich lecker ich
muss ehrlich sagen ist der gefühlte 50
zwetschgenkuchen schon so ähnlich
aussieht das ist kein zwetschke pochen
und heute geht es um das konzept wackelt
wir machen gerade ein basics morath und
damit sich kurz auf glas muss ich hin
vielleicht so geht um den teig und was
man daraus alles machen kann eben
teilchen kuchen sind rollen alles
möglich war stefan breznik riskiere
gewürfelte äpfel kirschen wo und wann
alles rest aus dem kühlschrank alle
einfach rein und fertig die suggestive
wirkung die macht des heftigen jahre war
wohl mit einem murat schmeckt und das
muss was heißen denn der murat ist
soviel süßkram und so viele torten und
kuchen thema probieren muss roger
schmidt genial dass das echte leben
arbeit sagt er probiert nur ist ein
ganzes stück also falls ihr denn kraft
und halt mal nachmachen wollt schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei aufs eis - blog.de
ich bin schon auf eure kreationen
gespannt was sie auf jeden fall und
markiert mich auf eure fotos also viel
spaß beim backen und bis zum nächsten
schuljahr aber du willst gar keinen
ganzen stück ist aber er schmeckt lecker
mich dermaßen liebliche waren über alles
[Musik]